pleased to have coleus Campbell new to
that Jacksonville defense right here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you coleus
good person like that I bet I bet before
we get into your side of things I got to
talk about this kid for net I mean we
had him on the show before the season
and I thought special things were gonna
happen obviously seeing him at LSU and
now we've seen this first five games is
a professional what is it like being on
the sidelines watching him run to
football class so it's definitely
special you know we get excited in the
way to hold on a block form and see the
way he just falls forward you know I'd
be on the jitters
but what about the attitude with which
he runs oh man it's so serious man I
love where he lowers a pad you know
buddy's kind of shifty to you has a
little bit of everything you know it's
just developing he's gonna do better I
don't know if you saw it if you were
doing something else in the sideline
talk in your position coach your
teammates but him coming around the end
yesterday at one point and waving it
Mike Mitchell essentially mid-run to
come get some did you see that
Callay what's he thinking yeah I love
that mentality my gosh so you coming I
want you to as you see me coming and
we'll see the best man I imagine
nobody's ever waved at you to come get
some class correct and you know what is
what did you guys say to him when he
came back on the sideline after that I
was just like yeah it was a good run I
mean he is just really something else
because I think that just sitting there
watching it it likes me up sitting just
sitting on a couch what what is it like
for the team to see something like that
in the midst of a of a big battle he
brings a lot of energy to the tent no I
he's just he's a big personality he
loves the game he's so passionate and to
see the way you play the game you know
our minutes definitely are motivated
Callay husband for example Callay is
Campbell here on the Rich Eisen show for
the Jacksonville Jaguars now let's get
into what you guys did yesterday
how did you approach this scene on film
seeing what you could do to Pittsburgh
that few teams are able to do in that
building
Callay yeah we knew we had a big
challenge but we knew that um you know
we take away the run game and make them
one-dimensional where DBS and our
passwords you know something's got to
give and so I know we did a good job
staying focused and job control and
keeping Lindsay on bottled up and then
you know we try to put pressure on them
and our Big Ben is a great quarterback
he's missing big-time throws but you
know when they came down to it you know
our DBS you know took advantage of some
of the ones that were 50/50 balls well I
don't know if you heard Big Ben's
comments after the game it's been
something that's been much discussed in
the media and certainly in western
Pennsylvania where it sounded like Ben
was being somewhat sarcastic that he
didn't have it anymore perhaps but in
light of him in this offseason pondering
retirement and then coming back a lot of
folks thought maybe there might be some
truth to that did you
while you are playing against Ben
Roethlisberger on Sunday feel like you
were playing against a quarterback who
wasn't all there mentally no way you
know he was he was focused in Sunday and
you know I think it was kind of just you
know he knows how the media's gonna play
there'll be five interceptions you know
no touchdowns held everybody setups I
just kind of didn't and head of the
bullet but you know on a football field
you know I you saw the fire in his eyes
you know five minutes ago down two
scores you know he's gonna try to make
something happen and that drive was was
tough right we got bent on the field and
it was for a holding call you know he
made a big time throw you know I'm glad
that we were able to the open call and
it's about the end zone but uh you know
I expect Big Ben have a pretty huge
season now I know the answer to this
next question but I'm asking it for
those out there listening and watching
this that might be begging this question
would you know what a quarterback who's
not mentally all there because perhaps
he's thinking about retirement would you
know what that looks like during a game
playing I believe so I do you know it's
a difference you know you could see the
fire in people's eyes you know you can
see that passion love for the game you
said I want to win
you know and uh you know Big Ben still
has an empire so he is not one of those
quarterbacks that is actually thinking
with one foot out the door while he's
playing a football okay class Campbell
Jacksonville Jaguar defense event
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
and we mentioned obviously Leonard
fournette what about Jalen Ramsey and
this defense and the passion he brings
how does that permeate your defensive
group culeros oh no no one that those
guys on the back end you know locking
guys down with give us access at it you
know from there we just rush a little
harder
you know but then when I do so total
boys well you know that anytime you come
down with that ball and he does such a
good job you know just just give me a
guy's right up and and allowing us to
play the game you want to play you know
I got respect for how does this defense
compare to others that you've been on in
Arizona I think it's the most complete
defense I've been apart of you know I've
been person since pretty good
differences all levels from the top to
bottom you know pretty stacked well I'm
sure you know how the rest of the league
feels about Jacksonville and how you got
to see it to believe it over and over
and over again so let me ask you how
real is this team oh yeah well we're
definitely a real you know I think the
biggest thing you're showing the tour
cells that we could be consistent and we
could do a weekend of ikaw but there's
no doubt in anybody's mind now that when
we put it together and we do it the
right way we could beat anybody so why
is it so tough to be consistent my
opinion I believe is just a young girl
new pieces that's just out of those
other out you know but now we're just at
that point in the season where you know
we've got you know got to test in the
coma stage you know and learn from them
and now we have to put her head down and
cry yeah and now come the rams into your
house they did lose yesterday but we all
know what this offense is like and we
also know who number 30 is coming down
hill to come in here I mean what a
minute go for it what do you think you
know if I'm if I'm the Rams or anything
you know when you Scout us okay we get
to run game going we got
because the two teams that we lost to
we're here for a whole lot of yards you
know so I'm not a girl who's you know
looking for opportunities and so we're
focused and I'll tell you what I run and
make things one-dimensional but at the
end of the day it's a really good thing
coming in you never won lose two in a
row so to come off a loss you know
coming to a you know a place that we
want to make a hostile environment you
know we have to develop that whole for
the vintage and that's gonna be huge for
us call for today is Campbell a couple
more minutes with him here on the Rich
Eisen show Congrats to your Cain's
beatin Florida State right there did you
give jaylen Ramsey any grief for that Oh
what did I mean before the game I try to
talk to him and tell the Smith after the
game they're back I wouldn't shut up
about it you know I took a call the
player still this for me to set up did
you hear Michael Irvin's reaction do you
see it on Twitter oh yeah yeah I feel
like I wish I felt the exact same way I
just don't record it mmm what does it
mean I guess for you what did what does
this victory mean to finally beat
Florida State after seven straight
losses
I support game for me you know shoot you
know we needed that I think it was more
mental than there was anything else
because they were in a better table for
the last couple of years but it was just
putting overtime meant to hurt oh and
then this every day you know it wasn't
pretty definitely made a lot of mistakes
but yeah Kaleo thanks for joining us
after the the win over Pittsburgh good
luck against the Rams and we'll chat
with you down the line good always a
pleasure
you got it at Campbell 93 on Twitter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy